for the past year black lives matter has
been everywhere on Facebook Twitter and
in the news it's been hard to ignore how
racism has dominated the headlines more
people are realizing that when it comes
to economic status and race parts of
America are as segregated today as they
were 50 years ago
and nowhere is that segregation more
obvious than in public schools when the
Supreme Court ruled on segregated
schools in 1954 it said that separate
facilities are unequal and that equality
in education was fundamental for any
child success integrated schools mean
better opportunities for more kids
studies show the low-income kids and
low-income schools do badly but
low-income kids attending middle income
schools tend to do a lot better to end
segregation school districts across the
country had to bust kids to different
schools to make sure they're as diverse
as possible and it worked
school integration reached its highest
point in 1988 but now US schools are
almost as segregated as they were in the
60s so what happened wealthier parents
are able to move their kids to better
schools and because poverty is often
grown along racial lines in America
better schools tend to mean whiter
schools underfunded schools that perform
badly tend to be mainly black and Latino
over the years the courts have relaxed
integration orders in districts across
the country this has allowed these
districts to attempt to keep wealthy
families from moving away by ending the
busing programs or by redistricting to
carve out schools for wealthier kids the
result is more white kids attending
schools with fewer black and Latino
students and more black and Latino
students are going to schools with few
or no white kids at all in fact the
number of what some call apartheid
schools schools that are less than one
percent white has almost tripled since
1988 so why are school districts so keen
to keep white kids at the cost of
segregating their schools again while
money is a big factor when wealthier
families move away they take their tax
revenue with them that means less tax
revenue to build schools and
neighborhoods and this isn't just an
issue in the south it's across the
country the state with the most
segregated schools New York this race
and class segregation has left us with a
two-tier education system where it's
almost impossible for schools and poor
areas to keep
I feel like you sold my segregation in
American schools so simple answer
because it's so much bigger it's so much
their greatness still in America Stephen
Brown went to school in Florissant
Missouri a few miles from Ferguson where
the black lives matter movement grew to
national prominence instead of a teacher
actually standing up at the board and
explain Lee they filled after like they
litter as a paperboy do all over that's
not an isolated case as the black
population of the school rises teachers
are likely to be less experienced or
qualified and more likely to rely on
less engaging teaching methods like
pre-made packets in fact by the time
they enter the eighth grade black
students are already three years behind
their white peers in math and reading
and the majority of so-called dropout
factory high schools are schools with
many black and Latino populations most
of the kids didn't didn't go off to
college
most of them some of them end up getting
on fire most of them I heard about
either they locked up or they'd be on
the other side predominantly white
schools tend to isolate their students
from other racial groups which also can
have a long-term effect when these kids
grow up to become cops politicians or
even teachers